so we're asked to choose the equation
that can represent the hyperbola graphed
below and so this is the hyperbola
graphed in blue and i encourage you to
pause the video and figure out which of
these equations are represented by the
graph here
all right so let's think about it this
graph opens to the left and the right
well i guess the first thing we can
realize it's centered at a zero so it's
definitely it's just going to have the
form
x squared and y squared over two
different things equaling one
and we know that it opens to the left
and the right you can think of it it
opens along the x direction and so we
know that the x term is going to be
positive here which tells us that the y
term is going to be negative
and we know that the vertices here are 5
to the right of the center and 5 to the
left of the center and so since the
distance from the vertices to the center
is 5 in the horizontal direction
we know that this right over here is
going to be 5 squared
or 25
25 and this we don't quite know just yet
i'll just call this i'll just call this
a squared
a squared we don't know what a is now
let's look at these choices here
x squared over 25 minus y squared over
nine equals one well that seems to match
the
pattern that i was able to generate
really quickly just looking at the graph
so i like this one this one has the x
term being negative so this graph over
here this would open up up and down not
to the left and the right so we can we
can rule this out
this one over here this has x squared
over nine that would imply that our
x-intercepts are
are plus or minus three
to the right and left of the center not
five and clearly they aren't plus or
minus three so we could rule this one
out
this one has the y term being positive
and the x term being negative so once
again this would open up and down so we
could rule that one out as well and so
our first choice that we liked that
matched our pattern we can feel pretty
good about it now if you wanted to
verify the 9 or if you want you might
want to try out some other points or
solve some points if it wasn't multiple
choice but in this case we are able to
pick out that this is the only one that
even matches the the general structure
that we were able to deduce